Bonjour, aujourd'hui nous allons jouer à un jeu extrêmement bizarre
puisqu'on va séduire un putain d'homme cheval
on est sur "My prince Horse"
Avec un accent incroyable
On va s'appeler "HORSEWHEREAREYOU"
Voila...et ben Non on peut pas c'est trop long
Et ben Parfait!
Une première vanne qui tombe a l'eau
C'est très rapide hein ça va très vite maintenant
ouais vas y on va s'appeler "Isabelle"
ben ouais j'ai pas d'inspi'
Oh mon dieu ça commence
qu'est ce qu'on est en train faire?
un ranch plutôt normal dans une ville plutôt normale
Un putain d'HOMME CHEVAL!
t’appelles ça quelque chose de normal?!
j'ai fait tout ce long voyage jusqu'à ce petit pays pour une seule chose
je me suis barré d'une grosse compagnie pour construire ma propre carrière
mais un jour j'ai perdu de vue ce que je faisais
je n'étais pas désintéressé du travail en lui-même
Mais je n'avais pas la chance...(rire)
mais je n'avais pas la chance de rencontrer des mecs beaux
j'arrête pas de penser que là c'est un homme-cheval
qu'elle va rencontrer donc ça me fait marrer p*****
je me donnais tellement dans mon travail que ma seule interaction avec les hommes c’était au bureau
un bureau plein de salariés d'âge moyen
que personne ne trouvait attractifs
et la jeune fille en moi attendait de l'excitation, et c'est là que j'ai réalisé
mon prince charmant ne se montrera jamais tant que je serais coincé dans ce bureau
donc j'ai décidé de prendre les vacances dans ce ranch
Pourquoi un ranch te demandes-tu ?
et ben parce que
*Musique*
My Horse Prince
Episode 1:le premier galop (rire)
hey je t'ai jamais vu avant
attends mec
ils ont dessiné une meuf cool d'animé et après ils se sont lâchés sur un dessin pourri
C'était trop demandé de faire que des persos cool d'animés
Hey Est-ce que ce ranch a des chevaux ?
Bien sur on entraine des chevaux à la course ici
Est-ce qu'il y a des beaux gosses qui viennent?
Des beaux gosses? On a des jockeys
Ah ok.. oh  mer** on dirait pas que mon prince se trouve ici
Tu es ici pour voir des chevaux?
Oh, euh, ouais
Ok il y en a un juste là, va le regarder de plus près
C'est un homme cheval ou un cheval normal hein ?
Il est juste là
C'est un jeu japonais hein si jamais, si jamais...
Oh mon dieu il est tellement sexy!
Cool fonctionnalités n'est-ce pas ?
Son nom est Yumma
Mais il a une tête d'humain ?!
Une belle tête d'humain
Madame, ne me dites pas que ...
Que tu vois un homme à la place du cheval ?!
Eh ben si et il est hyper sexy
Laisse moi deviner, tu es de l'année du cheval ?
Oui c'est ça
J'ai entendu que certaines filles étranges nées l'année du cheval
... voient parfois les chevaux comme des hommes très sexy
Les gens avec cette habilité sont vraiment très spéciaux
Pfff, non mais c'est quoi ce délire !
Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe ?
Casse-toi avec ta tête d'humain sur un vieux cou de cheval put**
Ahhhh ! il parle !
Je ne t'ai jamais vu avant
Putain en plus il fait le beau gosse quoi ...
Qu'est-ce qui t'amène ici ?
Je cherche juste des mecs sexy ...
Putain la meuf elle est en chaleur totale
C'est un chat, un vrai chat !
Oups, j'aurais jamais dû dire ça
Oui.
En passant, t'es quoi exactement ?
Je suis juste un cheval de course parfaitement normal
Il y a rien de normal avec toi !
Je suis si étrange que ça ?
Mais je te déteste pas pour autant
Ah il veut pécho quand même hein
Avec son putain de cou de cheval là
Hein ? Est-ce que ce mec m'aime bien ?
Pffff *rire*
Talent de comédien sa mère ...
Hein ? Est-ce que ce mec m'aime bien ?
*Foule en délire*
Non je ne peux pas penser à ça, c'est un cheval ! Un putain de cheval !
Il hennit !
Du verbe hennir, c'est le bruit que les chevaux font, c'est ça ?
Missy, pourquoi tu ne lui donnes pas un peu de nourriture ?
Attends, attends ...
Ils vont pas nous faire acheter de la monnaie du jeu ...
... pour acheter des packs d'eau au putain de cheval là
Hein ?
Non ! On mettra pas un billet
Y a des carottes juste là, donne lui en
Oh, ok.
Putain mec ... Ca va être dérangeant
OOOH ! Mais pourquoi ?
Mais non !
C'est comme un Tamagotchi
WTFFF
Tape sur la carotte pour nourrir Yuma
bien sur
mais fait attention il perd de l’énergie si tu le nourrit trop
ok
Et n'oublie pas de lui parler en cliquant sur le bouton
Allez amuse-toi !
Ooooooooh!
Donc là je le nourris
Energie 30%, ça va lui donner de l'énergie ?
Ouais.. Ah non il se met à m'aimer mais il perd de l'énergie
C'est ça ?
*Rires*
Et le but c'est qu'il m'aime ?
Non mais mec !
Oooooh !
Il faut absolument qu'on termine ce jeu !
J'veux voir la fin moi , j'veux voir le bisou !
Put*** comment il enchaîne la bouffe
Attention ! Ton énergie !
Ton énergie..*rires*
Il arrive plus à s'arrêter
Ouais mais là , il a plus d'énergie mon gars , regarde
Il...son cou il pend , son cou est pendu
Attend , il faut que je lui parle
Qu'est-ce que tu penses des carottes ?
Ah d'accord ça part en QCM !
On part en QCM .. *rires*
Euh.. elles ont un bon goût !
J'aime leur couleur orange .
ou, je ne les aime pas .
Elles ont un délicieux goût mec !
Allez embrasse-moi !
Il a gagné 15% d'énergie , ça va
Temps avant la prochaine fois que tu peux lui parler :
29 minutes !
Nooooon !
Mais noon !
Je veux lui parler maintenant !
J'veux....
Ah non c'est bon !
Est-ce que tu aimes les ranchs ?
J'dis oui...la réponse A comme toute à l'heure , en mode j'vais dans son sens ?
Non , j'vais la jouer en mode mystérieux
Pas vraiment...
T'as pas besoin de revenir si t'aimes pas ...
Oh noooon !
Ooooooooooooooh nooooon , hooo !
Attend faut que je lui parle
Faut que je lui parle..
Est-ce que tu aimes les ranchs ?
Ouais carrément !
Ils sont cools n'est-ce pas ?
Tu as de bons goûts !
Excellent !
Il gagne combien de pourcent d'énergie ?
+ 30
Put*** j'suis bien !
Allez j'vais arriver au bout !
Put*** il a plus d'énergie mec
Il nous manque tellement rien vas-y j'men fout je le fais tomber à 0
C'est bon ,c'est bon il en gagne un peu ...
Alors !
Tu m'aimes ?
Ton bond est devenu plus fort ..
Il a clairement beaucoup mangé aujourd'hui !
Il mange comme un cheval
Probablement parce que... c'est un cheval
*rire forcé*
Mais ce sera le dernier repas de la pauvre bête
Attend quoi ?
Son propriétaire vient de le quitter ,tu vois.
Ah mer**
Oh , c'est terrible !
Pauvre petite chose ,je me sens désolé pour lui maintenant
Si seulement quelqu'un pouvait s'occuper de lui ...
Ah lala , si seulement !
Thud thud thud
C'est quoi ça WTF ?
*rires* wtf...
thud ?
aaaaah !
Il m'a marché dessus !
Thud !
Il va me faire un câlin ?
*petite musique et battements de cœur*
hey !
hein ?
Qu'est-ce q'il se passe ?
est-ce que c'est ce truc qu'on voit dans les films ?
veux-tu devenir mon propriétaire ?
oh !
ok ..
Cool j'ai hâte de travailler avec toi mon proprio'
Oui ...
Premièrement peux-tu baisser ce sabot et te calmer un peu ?
*rires*
Attend... je suis sa propriétaire maintenant ?
Est-ce une menace ?
Il y a une période de réflexion n'est-ce pas?
Mais je peux sentir mon cœur s'emballer ...
Est-ce que ça pourrait être ..?
*musique*
Oh non !
*rires*
C'était hilarant !
Oh put*** ! Oh lalalalaaaa !
Bon voilà c'est la fin de l'épisode 1
C'était génial !
Quel est le 2e épisode ?
Isabelle a reprit ses esprits et est revenue à la ferme pour dire qu'elle la quittait
Mais noon !
Mais tu peux pas laisser , ton.. l'homme de ta vie !
Mais elle n'a pas réussi à trouver les bons mots en regardant ce visage si beau
Et donc Yuuma a demandé à Isabelle de commencer à l'entraîner
Mais Isabelle est sous le choc !
Dans le prochain épisode , la formation sur un tapis roulant !
Une fille amoureuse...
*rires* d'un cheval au visage d'homme ...
Et voilà , le rideau se ferme !
Voulez-vous écrire une review ?
Bah allez ! Allons-y !
5/5
Mais clairement : La définition de la qualité , mieux que la Ps4 pro et gratuit !
voilà !
C'est cadeau !
C'est pour vous !
Et bah voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous a plus
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à l'aimer
bah écoutez j'espère que moi aussi je trouverai .. mon prince charmant ...
Au corps de cheval
avec un....
un très très gros pénis
et bah voilà ! quand le Japon frappe , qu'est-ce que ça donne ?
de la qualité mon gars !
eh ! As-tu vu la note ?
4.9 mon gars !
*rires*
on part sur un buzz !
C'est gratuit ! Téléchargez-le tous , tous on le fait monter en Number 1 de France !
On se marie tous avec un put*** de cheval au visage d'animé
Allez merci d'avoir regardé , portez vous bien , ciao tout le monde...!
*intro finale*